should you start a non-profit so while
ago I made a video talking about
nonprofits versus for-profit
organizations and my advice if you're
indifferent between the two you don't
know if you should start a non-profit or
for-profit I advise going for the profit
company instead of a nonprofit
organization the reason is I think you
can have a lot more impact in the world
if you start a for-profit company you
can be in a lot more control of your
revenue stream and not be constantly
dependent on government grants and
donations to support your organization
one of my youtube viewers write in love
you guys
Nathan who asked what your opinion about
starting a non-profit change if you are
able to secure grant money from the
government so first of all let me say
before all the haters and the little man
sprout up I love nonprofits and I do a
lot of investing and help with nonprofit
organizations I just think you can have
a greater impact if you are in the
for-profit business and that opinion
doesn't change if you get a government
grant because that's how nonprofits
support themselves right it's government
grants and people in corporations giving
donations and there is there's a tax
incentive to support nonprofits in that
way the problem that I don't like with
nonprofits if you're not in control of
your revenue stream you're always
dependent on somebody being nice and
giving you money and that government
grant may disappear next year right so
you you get this grant you go out you
hire people you start doing projects and
then what do you do if that money is not
there next year
what you're gonna fire everybody what
are you gonna do your mission stops
right I like being in control of my own
destiny
and you can do that by having a company
and then using the proceeds to support
whatever initiatives you want right and
the more money you make with your
business the more you can support any
initiative that you want to do yourself
a great example is Elon Musk who was one
of the founders of PayPal and used the
money from his sale to start off his own
private enterprises
with Tesla and SpaceX and with with
Tesla
he's revolutionising the way cars are
built in America and hopefully around
the world he's trying to move a country
from being so dependent on gas to using
electricity and he's he's so adamant
about this that all of his patents he
put out opens and said hey Ford you can
use my patent a GM use my patents I want
to get these gas-guzzling cars off the
street I want everybody to be driving
electric cars that's his that's his
mission and he's done it by building
companies and he's having a major impact
on the country on the world now it's not
that a non-profit can have an impact
they can nonprofits have an amazing
impact all around the world it's just
harder because you're constantly
depending on people being nice and
giving you their money and donations and
those things dry up they may not be
there next year and I just don't like
the uncertainty so if you if you're at
Nathan you're starting this nonprofit
you've got a government grant that's
awesome congratulations you know deal
with the government can be a huge pain
you're waiting so long to get your money
the the application process is
ridiculous but congratulations on
getting that grant and if your passions
to start up a non-profit then do the
nonprofit my advices are people who are
on the fence they're not sure what they
want to do I think you have a greater
impact going the for-profit route where
you have control over your revenue
stream over how you spend your money and
you can do what you want with it to have
a positive impact in the world that's my
advice
believe those are you watching I'd love
to know what you think profit nonprofit
leave it in the comment section below I
want to hear from you you like this
video click on the link in the
description to support me and click on
my face subscribe to the channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon